hey wordsmiths I would never dare leave
you feeling left out so I want to warn
you that the word we're discussing in
this video is exclude
exclude it's a verb it means to keep
someone or something out to prevent
access it can have a bad connotation or
feeling like keeping people from voting
excluding them from having a vote and it
can also have a neutral connotation or
feeling like excluding coffee from your
diet or something you'll also see it as
exclusion which is the noun form but for
now let's talk about its derivation
where does this word come from we got X
we got clued what's going on
here so we have two pieces of Latin here
x means out as an extend or expel those
two words mean to stretch out or to
drive out and then clude comes from the
Latin Cloud which means to close you
sometimes see this route pop up as clu
to so when you are excluded from
something you've been closed out a door
has been shut and you're on the wrong
side of it but for now let's open the
door to some similar words I'll put on
some music all right and you'll take
that time to come up with a few words
that also use clude or clu or X ready
let's
[Music]
go
here are some I thought up exclusive
which means special or limited related
to exclude right an exclusive Club is
very picky about who gets in some people
are going to be excluded from or kept
out of the club or an exclusive offer is
limited time only act now to conclude to
end something literally to cloth
together like drawing the curtains at a
theater or secluded meaning out of the
way or private from Latin Parts said
meaning apart and Cloud right so
literally to be closed off apart from
everything let's use exclude in some
sentences Wanda didn't mean to exclude
Bonnie she really did honestly forget to
invite her to the clam bake look at
Bonnie being so sad dreaming of clams
and potatoes and corn nobody's ever
invited me to a clam bake which is a New
England beach party they do what it
sounds like they they bake clams okay
let's try it now in the noun form and
continuing the theme strangely enough of
corn nural loved corn on the cob to the
exclusion of all other food so that
means he doesn't eat anything but corn
he excludes other foods which is not
great my dudes it's important to eat a
balanced diet word Smiths a good mix of
leafy greens and proteins and the USDA
recommended two to three new words a day
see it's right here on the my plate
graphic I didn't just put that there I
kid I kid obviously but but words are
good for you okay I'll see you in the
next one you can learn anything Dave it
out